it's just
accomplishing something that I've been
dreaming of you know my whole life
hearing balance that sentence from Adam
Silver you know I've dreamed of it so so
much that you know
I gotta cry man Eve Oscar Victor's
siblings there were tears for you guys
what has it been like watching your
brother in this Pursuit
that's amazing we're all so proud we're
very happy for you we are happy for the
family for the friends for everything
for the basketball that's so amazing
yeah yeah I know that I was gonna tear
in uh gonna have tears because every
time I thought of these settings like
with the first pick and everything I got
this little tears in my eyes and I knew
that I wasn't gonna let let them in my
eyes yeah that's crazy
[Music]
Victor I do have to ask you though you
have been labeled generational talents
so many people are thrilled about your
potential in the NBA and you have said
that you don't feel pressure because
it's just basketball how do you begin to
leave your mark on this league
you know I'm a I don't know you know
it's it's a tough League it's tough to
win to win this league you know many
players have tried to win three for
years for decades and haven't made it so
my goal is I'm gonna try and learn as
quick as possible because I want to win
that ring with the 12th pick in the 2023
NBA draft the Oklahoma City Thunder
select Derek Lively II from Duke
University
Derek Lively
from duke 82 blocks the most in the
season by a Duke freshman since block
became official in 85-86 but Lively's
story it's really just remarkable he's
sharing this moment you can see there
with his mother Kathy who played
basketball at Penn State and is the
reason that he plays he calls her a
superhero and Kathy had a 10-year battle
with cancer and thankfully went into
remission in July of 2022 and he told me
that his proudest moment it was using
his nil money to buy Kathy a house near
Penn State where she works now his
father passed away when he was young and
he told me that certainly as Adam Silver
just called his name their shared name
the one he shares with his father he
will be on his mind he's just an
incredibly special player and Bobby
marks I know you were able to have a
conversation with him
I was able to sit down with him and I've
interviewed a lot of draft prospects in
my tenure and there's only been two
Jimmy Butler in 2011 and Derek Lively
the second where it brought out my
emotions where I had to leave the room
here and certainly an incredible story
it means every something to everyone
this draft it means something extra
special to Derek Lively II a tremendous
young man he also used a portion of that
nil money to buy his father a tombstone
something that he was not able to have
up until this past year in the 2023 NBA
draft the New Orleans Pelicans select
Jordan Hawkins from the University of
Connecticut
National Champion Jordan Hawkins an
emotional moment that he is sharing with
his parents he's described his parents
as the hardest working people I know and
that everything I do is to make them
proud a moment with his agent Ty
Sullivan of CAA he has four siblings
that are also here
he shot 50 from the floor 21 of 42 from
three in his six game Run to the
championship with UConn a winning player
a big time player he improved his points
per game by just over 10 from two
seasons ago that's a huge jump the
largest actually by UConn player over
the last 25 years and of course you
might know his cousin fellow national
champion at LSU Angel Reese but Andrea
do you see glimpses of former husky
grapes in his game with the 16th pick in
the 2023 NBA draft the Utah Jazz Select
chiante George from Baylor University
[Applause]
chiante George from Baylor headed to the
Utah Jazz he scored 506 points last
season the second most in a season by a
freshman in Baylor history his dad was
actually a pro in France and he's come a
long way we spoke earlier this week and
he told me that when he was in high
school he had an abscess in his hip and
he was supposed to just be in the
hospital for a day but he was there for
weeks and he thought he'd never play
basketball again and really that gave
him a new appreciation day for the game
that he loves so very much yeah he is a
shot maker and a shot creator that
combination he's poised has a good feel
for the game especially on the offensive
end good quickness he's athletic and I
think he's got all the tools to be a
good Defender because one thing his
efficiency probably needs to improve uh
he had some turnovers took some tough
shots but he played on a team of shot
creators with LJ Pryor and Adam Flagler
that was the the best Trio of guards in
America that Scott drew had at Baylor
and Deontay George one of the the big
reasons why
pick in the 2023 NBA draft the Charlotte
Hornets select Nick Smith Jr
from the University of Arkansas
[Applause]
an emotional moment
for Nick Smith Jr for his family
sharing this with his parents Nick and
Candace his grandparents Gloria Michael
verlinda
he played Just 17 games last season but
he told me that he keeps it all in
perspective he said that's not true
adversity true adversity is not knowing
where your next meal is coming from and
that was the case for so many people
that he grew up with he said and that's
what he tries to keep in mind his
parents actually had him in college he
used to go to the gym with his dad
because they share an emotional Embrace
here this is just a reminder that this
isn't just about basketball this isn't
just about taking the next steps in the
NBA this is about dreams coming through
for human beings for real people and you
can see that emotion painted all over
his face as he is walking into his
future in the NBA just an incredible
moment for Nick Smith Jr and his family
extended hugs all around
because you really want to soak this in
this moment you know it only happens
once every single player that has heard
their name called undraft night
remembers that moment it will live as
part of their story and journey and it's
an incredible feeling and for someone
like him who was the number one player
in his high school class dealing with an
injury potentially could have been a
lottery pick had he not been hurt and
dealt with that last year waiting around
all night to hear his name called just
an incredible moment for this young man
play a level of high-level basketball in
high school
Leonard Miller getting his moment
with Deputy Commissioner Mark Tatum
sometimes when you wait around when you
are just hoping to hear your name
that Embrace this this is what makes
this so special JJ
it really is and the emotions coming out